Film Courage: When you write screenplays with
Jeff [Jeff Haskett-Wood - co-collaborator],
who usually comes up with the idea?
Ryan Harris, Filmmaker: A lot of times it’s
me.
I come to him with a bunch of crap and he
goes…he looks it over and goes Okay…let’s
take this piece and then it becomes more of
a back and forth version with each other.
He does come up with a lot of great ideas.
He has a lot of stories that he wants to tell.
A he’s really good about if he just wants
to write a script, he goes and does it and
then he’ll pass it to me and we’ll read
it over and I’ll throw in my two cents and
we’ll start.
I feel like we work really well together in
that aspect but it’s definitely I am the
one who pokes and prods him a lot more to
be like Hey let’s do this or let’s do
that and he patiently deals with me.
Film Courage: Where do these ideas come from?
Ryan: A lot of them just stem from stories
that I would love to see as a filmmaker, that
I would love to go to the movies and watch
and a lot of it comes from movies that I’ve
watched over and over and over again or a
lot of the inspiration comes from movies in
general.
You watch a scene and you think to yourself
that would be really interesting to…even
a line of dialogue that the character could
say you take that and you go that in and of
itself could be a story.
That is something that would be interesting
to explore so we just try to find things that
we would love to see as filmmakers and writers
and stories that we would love to
be told.
There
is actually a really interesting old Canadian
movie.
I say old, the late 90’s at it was called
When Good Ghouls Go Bad and it stars Christopher
Lloyd who is one of the most amazing actors.
Everybody knows him as Doc Brown in BACK TO
THE FUTURE but a lot of his stuff is serious
work and his comedic work is just fantastic.
So he has a line where he is speaking to his
son and his son basically says you know you
used to be this go-getter and the town is
dealing with passing of this person who got
stuck in this kiln overnight and the town
sort of deals with that heavy weight and the
dad basically says you know you used to be
happy, you used to be a go-getter, you used
to build things and make things and help people
and Christoper Lloyd says yeah and I built
the kiln that that person died in.
It’s one of those moments in that movie
where he didn’t need to say that, that didn’t
need to be a part of the movie, but it was
and that right there you go man that in and
of itself dealing with the trauma of doing
something you love and then that thing you
love hurts somebody, that in and of itself
could be an incredible story.
There are a lot of things in movies and I
try my best to write them down when I feel
them and see them and I hear them but that
would definitely be an example of something
that
has inspired me.